[Music]
hello everyone welcome to
talk to you the cloud my name is
thibault by je suis clair de
consultants and google paris in this
episode we will set up
monitoring with driver style from the
fantastic tricotin website a start up  which has
grown faster than the
IT infrastructure on which it started
the company's needs and priorities
are to set up a reporting system
for processing alerts that is
as autonomous as possible with its schedule of
hours monitoring of your
environment and  greatly simplified and
automated all the metrics and
logs from the google cloud services
of your infrastructure and your
applications are sent directly
to sneijder who takes care of the rest for
you
let's see how it works here we are
in the interface of this tag driver  this
is the homepage with the
events on the left we can
navigate within the different services
we can see that cert  ain services are
centralized on this interface such
as monitoring alerting and
availability verification or obtain
chaix therefore independent of a
google cloud project in particular other
services however such as logging are
decentralized and therefore accessible by
project we can see some  the list by
placing the cursor on the corresponding service
let's talk about monitoring I created
a lamp-type web server running
on a computer jean instance I
want to take a closer look at the
indicators provided by this web server
use this drivers tag to watch
the data relating to this instance
first of all by opening the
resources menu this dreamy tag offers you
an instance category I select
the moment what I have just created on
the left we find the summary of
incidents and an event log
concerning  this instance on the right
we find graphs with the
key indicators of the instance
according to the temp  s cpu usage
ayo disk and networks we can increase
the time scale to identify
anomalies such as a peak in
network traffic
you can also create
your own graphs and
organize them
this driver tag also allows you to create
your own personalized dashboards
let's look at this together in the dashboard menu
we will click on shouts and dashboard let's
add a new graf
we have access to the metrics explorer
here we can search for any
metrics among those available
i.e.  that emitted by
google cloud services such as
computer jinkyu bernetti saint jean
cloud storage or big wave choose the
number of writes on disk
wright disk in English and save our
graph
we now have a dashboard with
a graph representing the number
of writes  on disk of our website
you can also find
the metrics explorer in the metric
resources section  Let's explore and
here is an example of a dashboard we
give an overview of our
infrastructure
I now suggest that you move on to
the leyre thing the creation of alerts will
prove to be very useful to warn the
teams in charge of your
infrastructure you will seek to
alert following a proven problem
but also in anticipation of
signals that would avoid
real service failures for this this
dreamy tag allows you to set
up automatic alerts by creating
hing or police alert rules
let's set up a police to be
alerted by e-mail when the
cpu consumption of my instance is
excessive
let's say above 80% for about
twenty minutes
we go to the menu alerting create
police have chosen the conditions in
which we wish to be  alerted
in this case we filter on computer
jean then choose the name of our
instance we then choose an
e-mail notification  l let's appoint seven
lamp cpu spike policemen and
save when our instance undergoes
an increase in cpu usage
we will be alerted by e-mail
the event will also be registered in the
event log seen previously
let's now move on to logging this one
is important for  understand what is
happening in your instance and it is very
useful for diagnosis when a problem
appears logging is done through
the styles driver agent based on the
open source
software ndi which is installed by default on
our instance and which is  'run
with service 50 of this one
the logging agent collects all the relevant logs
such as those coming from our
web server and sending them to the stack
driver here is the logging interface beyond
water projects
we have a search bar that
allows us to find certain blogs
more quickly we will first filter the
logs corresponding to our instance have
chosen by viet-minh stearns and we
click on the inst  ance the empa vm
we will then filter by error to
see all the errors log and by this
one we can use this filter with the
lootings by converting it into
advanced filters and use it in a request
it is sometimes necessary for
reasons of  'audit and compliance
to export certain blogs with this
reiver login tag we can create
log exports based on a filter with
the destination of other services such as
cloud storage for archiving cloud pop
alone to send the logs in real time
to other systems and big three to
do advanced log analysis we
will create an export log to a
bucket on cloud storage to archive c
log we go to the languages
orts section for our web server we filte
the logs for  keep only those
of our server then we click on
eight languages export have chosen its cloud
storage analysts we can see t
at our logs have been exported to gc
and classified by date
appearance then by type of log exported
certain important metrics in
monitoring are often extracted
from the logs themselves, for example a
way to recover the number of errors
from our web server and to count the
number of logs and distribute them by
level of  error then create a
metric ogbl we can then
use this new metric from a
stack driver monitoring and even create
an alert as we showed
previously
when the number of errors increases
too note that this metric
already exists by default and  is named the
crisis organ we are now interested in
monitoring reiver-style applications a
few services meeting this need
reporting heroes 13 profilers and
burgers its services allow us to
understand what is happening in your
applications and help you
improve them  performance
let's start with the error
reporting service sometimes it is very useful to be
able to observe all the errors of
our apps  cations which helps us to
identify and fix bugs
the dayraut reporting interface is made
to automatically detect
errors in our lodges with their stack
trace in context to help us
debug a modern application and
often composed of micro services that are
send requests to each other to
visualize their communications
distributed supervision systems
such as star driver trice are very
effective
here we can observe the breakdown
of a request observe the latency of
each of the requests and deduce, for
example, which services are
taking the  more time to answer
sometimes we need to have
precise information about the timing of
each of the methods of our
application stage driver profilers
answers this need and allows
developers to improve the
performance of their applications by
measuring the cpu time users  and
systems memory requirements and the like
it is also often necessary to  having
powerful debugging tools for
your applications bug driver style
is a service that allows us to
do live debugging by adding
tip breaks to our applications
we can also see the values of the varia
les when the break for goal is re
ch
d us  we have seen how to use this tag
drivers to increase the visibility on
the fantastic knitting infrastructure
we have presented the main
interfaces and functionality you
will find in the description of the
video links
to resources that you can
consult to deepen some of the
concepts we have  just spoke
thank you very much for your attention and see you
soon
[Music]